So at this point, this was like one bug.
It could be critical already.
Like one of the team members found it and filled it as is.
But there was that way more to achieve.
And my mind said, okay, let's see how many users are in the organization.
We wanted to pre-vesque, right?
So what's the best common way to pre-vesque from this environment?
Let's find stale accounts, you know, dead accounts, maybe with expired emails.
That was my thinking.
In numerating, I managed to fetch all the users.
There were over 200k accounts in that environment.
Oh my gosh.
You're kidding.
Best part of hacking when you can just, you know, critical thing, right?
What's up, y'all?
Before we hop into this episode, two quick things.
One, we intended to do some giveaways on this episode, but then we forgot completely to integrate
it into the episode in any way, shape, or form.
So we're going to make it easy for you guys.
Just head over to c2pb.show slash giveaway 100.
Obviously, giveaway and then episode 100, giveaway 100.
And we're just going to make it super simple for you to enter your name there and get access
to entering your name for the giveaways that we've got.
We're going to give away some Kaido licenses.
We're going to give away ctbb swag.
We're going to give away premium Discord subs.
And we're going to give away Shift AI beta access.
Now that brings us to the second point.
What is Shift AI beta access?
Well, I'm glad you asked.
We're going to talk to you more about that at length at the end of this episode after the bug that Rezo presents.
But essentially, the TLDR of it is Shift is a new Kaido plugin that Joseph Thacker and I have created.
And it was inspired by Cursor AI.
So I'm not sure if any of you guys have used Cursor, but it's a new IDE where you can just kind of prompt in natural language what kind of app you want.
And it just builds out the whole app for you.
It's phenomenal.
And when we saw this, we thought, wow, wouldn't it be amazing if we could bring something similar to hacking?
So that's what we did.
Rezo is the backend engineer for the AI stuff on the front end for Kaido integration.
And we built a tool that can do really cool stuff like you can paste a JS snippet in, and it will automatically generate the replay request body that's being described in that JS snippet.
You can highlight a set of feature flags in the response in Replay in Kaido and say, hey, add a match and replace rule for me to turn all these feature flags on and boom, the match and replace rules right in your Kaido configuration.
So it's a really great tool.
We've been loving it.
We're launching it.
So if you're interested, head over to shiftwaitlist.com.
Drop your email there.
Yeah.
So two things.
ctp.show slash giveaway100 to enter the giveaways.
And then shiftwaitlist.com to join the waitlist for that awesome Kaido AI plugin.
All right.
That's it.
I've rented enough.
Let's go back to the show.
All righty, man.
Here we are.
100 episodes.
You know, after 100 episodes, you still jump up and down and get nervous before these things.
Dude, I do.
Every episode.
You got to get that energy high.
That's what the people deserve, Joel.
That's what the people deserve.
Yeah.
Dude, I'm proud of us.
100 episodes.
Give me some, man.
Give me a fist bump through the screen right now.
I'm going to mess up on my camera's focus.
But dude, as you guys, I guess, addressing the audience, as you guys have probably seen
from the title, we have some announcements today with regards to Joel.
And Joel, thanks so much for coming along on this journey with me, man, for the past two
years.
It's been a blast.
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, it's been really awesome doing the podcast the last few years.
You know, in terms of why I'm leaving, it's mostly just personal reasons.
You know, I wasn't feeling super engaged with the pod.
You may have noticed I haven't been on episodes lately.
It's just been sort of difficult for me to balance everything that I'm doing along with
the podcast.
So I think we decided that it would be better for me to step back.
And I'll probably be on as a guest.
At least I know we have one planned.
So I'll definitely be on as a guest at some point.
So I'm not going anywhere.
But yeah, I will be stepping back from the pod.
Yeah, man.
You know, it's been really crazy that you've done this for two years in addition to full
time job, in addition to Bug Bounty, right?
Because in order to be able to be the co-host of this podcast, you kind of have to actively
be like hacking on stuff too to get the juices flowing and the passion, you know, running.
And for me as a full time hunter, it's easy for me to like fit that into my schedule while
doing the podcast.
But, you know, even for me, the podcast takes up a bunch of time.
And I couldn't imagine you having another whole 40 hour thing and trying to get hacking done
and trying to do the podcast.
So, dude, major props to you for hanging in there for two years.
And I had to get to 100, you know, even if I was kind of like being dragged the last
mile.
It's like a marathon, you know?
It's me and you.
And you got your buddy and you're like, listen, we're getting over that fucking finish line,
whether you like it or not.
Oh my God, dude.
Shit, Joel, don't make me laugh, man.
I'm going to tear up and I'm going to miss this, dude.
I'm going to miss this.
But yeah, I think it's the right choice.
I think it's the right choice for you.
I think it'll, you know, make you feel less stressed.
It'll free up time, allow you to really kind of pour back into your passions.
And yeah, I mean, I think the Critical Thinking podcast will go on.
I hope.
Yeah, it has been.
It has been.
It's only going to keep getting better.
So yeah, I mean, I'm really excited to see what's going to, you know, keep going on with
the pod.
Now I get to listen to it more as a listener, which is fun instead of like being having
the spoilers for every single episode.
So that's fun.
But yeah, dude, it's been amazing.
And, you know, thanks for caring what I've been lacking.
And yeah, it's been amazing.
Of course, man.
Got your back always.
And yeah, we'll definitely be having you on for guests and as a guest.
And yeah, definitely pinging you for any mobile stuff that I need help with as always.
Yeah, cool, man.
Cool.
All right.
So last episode, we are 100th episode, not last episode, my last episode.
We've got a little special something.
We do.
We got a lot on the docket.
What we did for this one, because we wanted to bring you guys something special for the
100th episode, we reached out to, geez, how many hackers did it end up being here?
Let's take a look.
I think we have eight hackers from Critical Thinking this year that have been on the pod
or been friends of the pod.
And we asked them, what was your favorite bug from 2024?
One that you thought was creative.
It doesn't necessarily have to be the most impactful, though most of them are very impactful.
And we asked those hackers what, you know, about those bugs, to share those bugs with us.
And they kindly did.
So this episode is going to be kind of diced up a little bit.
It might be a little bit choppy because we're going to be kind of jumping back and forth
from the time that I recorded with these top hackers to, you know, back to today where
Joel and I are sort of commenting on them.
As long as Joel can hang in there.
Joel, I know you're sick right now, but he's bringing his A game to the last episode.
So let's go ahead without further ado and jump into one of those.
First up on the list is Natalie.
Let's check out his bug from 2024.
Yep.
So it wasn't that hard for me to pick the biggest bug of 2024 for me because there was only one
which actually required for me to do a lot of steps on it.
It was also a collaboration.
And it's like now that I started working at Weed, it was also pretty interesting to see
like cloud, you know, the world is not only related to bug bounty and external stuff.
You can also do a lot of stuff on the inside, which is interesting.
And so we can get right into it.
And so this was a target which allowed to hack everything that belongs to the target.
That's always good.
So we start on the internet, you know, like everything is on the internet.
It needs to be publicly accessible at first.
Now, usually targets allow us to find anything.
So you have star at travel.com, this is like the codename that we chose here.
So what you do now, you know, subdomain discovery, subfinder, brute forcing, fuzzing, permutations,
and so on and so on and so on.
If it takes you less than five minutes, you're doing something wrong because it should take
you a lot more to find all those assets.
And so that's on that part.
So we dive deep on that.
We found all the subdomains, a lot of iterations.
Nothing really interesting, you know, on that part.
Now we don't only have DNS assets of the company under the root domain.
There's a lot of cloud resources that companies use.
SV buckets, lambdas, Azure blobs, Google storage, and so on and so on and so on.
So, you know, these are not really affiliated with the company sometimes.
You can have random naming arbitration.
It doesn't need to be travel.agrewebsites.com to be their asset.
So there's a lot of ways and a lot of tools to find cloud resources from the outside,
either references on JavaScript files for main domains, either URL scan, either way between,
either some references that redirects, you know, from different domains to cloud domains,
which are not affiliated with the company but might have data there.
So that was this case.
We managed to find one cloud resource, which didn't have the company inside it,
but it had a redirection to a domain of the company.
And on that domain, it was basically like nothing.
Azure website, three or two, to another domain that doesn't resolve.
Okay?
That was pretty interesting.
Like you get, you have a DNS, Azure website that redirects to a domain which is dead.
And, okay, so something has to make it redirect, right?
I mean, it doesn't, just out of the blue.
So it was a C02 redirect on the client side.
So whenever that happens, you have JavaScript to examine and to look at.
So in this case, there were a lot of JavaScript files.
Usually you'd want to look at the main, main.js or like the runtime.
And on, yeah, you can stop me if you have any questions so far.
No, no, no, I do have, I do have a question because it's like, I'm seeing this and it's saying in the JS files.
So were you reaching out to that specific cloud resource or like all cloud resources?
And then if it's a client side redirect, how are you, how the frick are you detecting this?
Are you like running all of these in like a headless browser and seeing where you end up?
Like how, how is that happening?
Yeah.
So you can use crawlers, like to fetch all the JavaScript files.
And then that should give you the files already.
Even if you use that, I think if you just use Katana or like any investigating crawlers.
Yeah.
There are also several tools like URLScan and others that if you search like travel.com, it shows you all the redirections to travel.com also.
Like where did the request originated from?
So if you look at like openai.com or like the files, like I was just playing with openai.
I saw the file, like the same attachments on weird domain or AI private files, something like that.
So if you look on this on URLScan, you will see all the websites that redirected you to that.
So you see a lot of HTTP, but you also see some, you know, like cloners and phishing domains and like HTTP mockups.
Like they stimulate HTTP on their infrastructure.
Then you can see the original resource.
So what happened here, we searched for a domain that doesn't resolve on URLScan.
And then we saw an actual Azure website asset that redirected to it.
So that way you can actually find cloud resources that are not connected to the asset.
Just pretty interesting.
That's super cool.
Yeah.
And so from that point, we had a JavaScript file and it had a lot of secrets.
And so one of the secrets had an Azure DevOps bear token, which was interesting to explore.
And we found out in the collaboration that we can actually invite ourselves to this environment, this company as a guest account on the tenant.
And so as a guest account, you have access to the Azure AD.
Not much, but at least, I don't know if it's default or not, but we could query, like do enumeration and see all the groups that exist.
And all the users that exist just by using the Azure CLI.
I think that is default.
Yeah.
I think it's different because you wouldn't expect someone to do something with that.
So at this point, this was like one bug.
It could be critical already.
Like one of the team members found it and filled it as is.
But there was like way more to achievement.
My mind like said, okay, let's see how many users are in the organization.
We wanted to pre-vesque, right?
So what's the best common way to pre-vesque from this environment?
Let's find stale accounts, you know, dead accounts, maybe with expired emails.
That was my thinking.
In numerating, I managed to fetch all the users.
There were over 200K accounts on that environment.
Oh my gosh.
You're kidding me.
So all we have is their username, their permissions, like which groups they belong to, and their email addresses.
So everything with like travel.com, remove it.
It's taken, you know.
So like you narrow down the list, gmail.com, remove it, and so on and so on.
Eventually, we go to a list of like 10,000 users that have been like self-fail detection on them and like expired domain detection.
To see if we have any name server zone takeovers, oh, we can buy them on Godly.
And around 50 domains were available for purchase.
Oh my gosh.
Like 100 accounts, which was pretty interesting.
I mean, okay, so we have now 100 accounts that we need to examine their permissions, and we can actually just get a password login.
We set up the 2FA also, so like no restrictions on that.
It was just a story of like, you know, if they only knew they have so many dead accounts for like five years of some consulting companies they use, you know.
If you look at the cloud a little bit from the inside, if you only saw a user that now we took over an account, and it wasn't active for six years, and now it's playing around.
I mean, you know, some light bulbs should build now.
I don't know how you say it.
I mean, it should spark maybe.
Yeah.
On that model.
Yeah, absolutely.
Well, it's crazy too, you know, like if you're issuing accounts, like AD accounts to like contractors, like you said, like that contracting company can just do like a rebrand or something, and now their domain is up for grabs, and that leads to that specific vulnerability.
So you really need to have a good grip on AD, I guess, hygiene in these sort of massive company environments, I think.
Yeah, I don't know how, I think it's pretty common to invite guests or like contractors to your AD because, you know, you don't want to play with like, it's Octa or it's Azure AD, it's all about permissions.
You don't want to set up account for individuals.
So it's pretty interesting.
I mean, once you get in, you know, we both experienced in Las Vegas one night with another Hunter, Corbyn, that once you get a little bit inside, it's, yeah, it's pretty insane where you can get to, yeah, privileges connection wise.
So that's like where we're at now.
So we found an account that we took over the email and we saw you had permissions to some other applications that we know based on the subdomains that there was an application with login page there with Azure.
So we wanted to try to take over that account and log into an internal application.
So that's what we did.
We managed to log in.
It didn't ask us for any 2FA.
And now we got into an internal CRM application.
And it looked like it was built in the 70s.
Oh my God.
There was nothing in the 70s, but it's still like, it looks something like that.
Yeah.
Like you know the feeling when you log in something.
And yeah, it was wild west.
It's got shag carpet everywhere.
Shag carpet and peace signs if it's from the 70s.
You know the feeling when you see like something that you say, okay, I can see the bugs already.
So you're mentally prepared to like, okay, it's time to walk.
No more bullshit around.
No more taking the time.
So straight away looking around like 10 to 15 minutes.
LFI is everywhere.
RCE is everywhere.
SSRF is everywhere.
Mass API leak everywhere.
Admin, SSRF to Azure metadata.
Admin access.
All the secret access.
Access to everything.
Which is, I mean, yeah, it's not a normal bug bounty story or bug because usually you stop at the secret.
Like you would usually stop at the bear token of day and like, hey company, I don't want to play with you anymore.
You validate the critical impact.
And I mean, it's the same critical, right?
Usually in terms of bug bounty.
This engagement they wanted us to do like, hey, show us the full impact and we will compensate you also.
If you find better impact than the normal impact of the bug bounty.
But yeah, it's like, it's not that usual, but it's pretty interesting chain.
It's like starting from the outside with no leads to like resources that are not related to the company.
And then so many anomalies the companies could see if they had like track.
Like there's so many points we could have got caught because it took two weeks.
Yeah.
What you see here.
Took two to three weeks.
And it sounds like it took five minutes, but it takes a lot of time to do.
But once you previous and get to the internal application, it's like the GG.
It was very fast.
You know, like once you get there.
I think this is a really, I think this is a really good example of like how you, you get pwned in a cloud environment.
You know, like leaking those, that bear on the outside, I think is, is one of those, one of those.
Very, very bad mistakes where you can, you know, then turn it from an external to an internal.
And once you're already in the internal, it's, it's game over in a lot of, a lot of ways.
It's just a matter of time before you get to the, the secrets of everything.
Um, so wow, dude, this is a very impressive one.
I can see why you chose this one.
This one's, this one's great.
Um, so thanks for sharing it, man.
Appreciate that.
Okay.
Wow.
That was, uh, that was cool, man.
Dude.
I hadn't heard it.
I hadn't heard that bug before from Nagly.
So that's, uh, it's always good.
He's always got some crazy stuff cooking.
Dude, the recon game on that bug was nuts, right?
Where he is actually identifying this leak by looking at what assets are client side redirecting
to an in scope asset.
That is nuts.
That's so much to sift through to find this.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
It's really cool.
Um, yeah.
And then I think the other cool thing about this one is just that you have such flexibility,
right?
With this program, they're letting you sort of pivot internally so much.
You, you mostly only get opportunities like this during pen tests typically.
And, uh, yeah, this time they just kind of let them have at it.
So props to the team on that one.
That one's, that one's a really cool bug that we probably wouldn't have been able to, to
hear about, uh, if, if they weren't so permissive with their bug bounty program.
So yeah.
Super cool.
All right.
Let's, uh, let's cut to the next one.
Shubs is up next.
So we're going to hear about some crazy shit for sure.
I'm excited.
Yeah.
Um, so essentially, uh, uh, if you guys, uh, know my MO and my style, I mostly focus
on preauthentication vulnerabilities that lead to critical server side, um, impact.
Uh, in this case, uh, w this was for a live hacking event, um, for, uh, for hack one.
And, uh, it was a specific vendor product, which, um, you know, has been looked at quite
heavily, not just by my team at asset note, but, um, pretty much hundreds of hackers over
the years.
And, and really this vendor software, um, has a Linux component or a windows component you
can install on a server.
Um, it is a really big, um, piece of software.
It has, you know, gigabytes of jar files and things like that.
But anyways, um, in all the different times that I've looked at this software over the years,
never been able to find something that's preauthentication.
And can, and lead to some sort of critical impact.
But this one was particularly interesting.
It was something that required like maybe six or different, six or seven different steps
in the exploit chain to get to command execution.
Oh my God, dude.
When we start off, you know, like we, we look at the process Explorer, we look at, um,
proc one, we see what processes are running in this vendor application and what different
technologies is there.
And, you know, it's, it's a wide variety of things in this one.
There's, you know, Apache HTTP server.
There's a lot of Java processes.
And then there's, you know, also one really peculiar node JS process, which we can get
into a little bit more now.
Now a lot of people, when they ship node JS server side code for these vendor applications,
they compile it to V8 bytecode.
When it is V8 bytecode, it is a pain in the ass to look at it.
You, you load it into Ghidra and you're like, what am I looking at?
I don't understand.
And there's, there has been some developments over time where some people have, you know,
being, have made it a little bit easier to look at, but it's still a total pain in the
ass.
And I don't think that, uh, I think that the main reason why people hadn't found stuff
in this node JS component is purely because they had compiled the node JS server side code
to V8 bytecode and no one spent the time to understand what was going on there.
And I don't blame them either.
We had also skipped this several times because we were like, we don't, we don't have the time
to spend on this, the first real breakthrough came when, um, came when I realized that,
uh, this entire component was accessible via the HTTP config, uh, in a way that was pre
authentication and it was responding in a way, which was basically saying like the URL is
missing.
Now that's, that's obviously, as you know, Justin, if you see something that says that
the URL is missing, you jump at that opportunity.
That is a big indicator.
The heart starts beating fast as soon as you see that.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
And, and you see something like that and you're like, okay, I really need to dig into this
more.
And, and what I found was it was a part of some SDK that this organization had made,
um, to create these special add-ons for the software.
And, um, you know, I just took a little bit of a stab in the dark and I found some SDK
documentation and a package on NPM.
Um, I downloaded that package and I found that actually all of the server side source code for
that component was within that package, which is amazing.
I mean, that, that made it so much easier.
Now I will caveat that with the fact that the server side source code was still, uh, in many
ways, obfuscated and minified.
Um, so it was still somewhat tricky to understand, but trust me, I'll take reading JavaScript over
reading V8 bytecode.
Yeah.
I will take that any day of the week.
Um, so yeah, I started digging into this and I started realizing that, wow, this is actually a really
complex component of this application such that it has this whole ecosystem that it provides of this SDK
and applications.
Um, there were several headers that you could provide, um, for this endpoint that would essentially load, um, a file from the disk, um, and load it into this application SDK sandbox environment.
Now.
You must've been so hyped when you saw this scope dude, when you were starting doing this stuff.
Oh, like finally something interesting pre-auth.
A hundred percent.
Yeah.
And, and that was, that was really interesting because, um, you know, the target we were looking
at for the event was a Linux system.
Um, but really, uh, the reason why this entire attack vector can be done pre-authentication on windows specifically is because of the fact that windows allows you to provide two backslashes, uh, and a, uh, a system volume.
And then suddenly that's going to reach out to connect via network share and pull data from there.
But essentially there was a header that loaded a file and on windows, obviously you can use the network share on Linux.
You actually have to have it to be a local file.
Um, okay.
So yeah, it was, it was really interesting.
So I was loading this and this file format for all intents and purposes was just a glorified zip file.
Um, uh, and inside the zip file was some JavaScript files and a manifest file, which basically dictated what this plugin would do.
Um, what's this supposed to be, do you know if this API was supposed to be used internally by the application or whether this was something that the client would actually hit at some point?
Yeah.
Well, that's the really surprising part.
I actually couldn't find any legitimate use for this in any way or form.
Um, I, I, I, I don't know if this was like some rogue developers side project that somehow got shipped to production or there was some really obscure feature somewhere.
But to be honest, everywhere in the application, there was zero references to this.
There was no real understanding of why this would be used legitimately.
It was some dormant feature that had been there for quite some time, but really didn't seem like it was, uh, actively used by the community in any way or form.
Right.
So definitely a little bit of dead code there, I think.
Um, but yeah, anyways, uh, that zip file, it had some, it had a manifest file.
It had some other JavaScript files and it started getting me thinking like, what's going on with this?
How is this executing?
And, um, it turns out that it was being executed within a isolated VM sandbox, which is, you know, not the worst thing.
It's a good sign that your service is being executed.
Good starting point.
Yeah.
But I also know from my experience that isolated VM, when it's updated to the newest version, it's actually quite tricky to bypass and escape.
Um, I'm pretty sure that, uh, isolated VM sandbox bypass escapes would be quite valuable in any sense.
So really what I started looking at was, um, the first thing I looked at was, uh, uh, the ability to get SSRF because this environment was on AWS and we could, you know, potentially we could, um, read the metadata IP, the security credentials, get access that way.
Um, so I started crafting that.
And, um, what I found was the first roadblock was I needed to somehow smuggle a zip file, uh, onto the local system and know the exact path of where that zip file was.
Um, this was a lot trickier than, um, than I thought it would be, but that was one of the first stages was getting that zip file there.
Once I was able to.
Especially pre-auth, right?
Like that's a big condition, but especially if you're trying to maintain the pre-auth-ness of this bug, that's a big precondition.
A hundred percent.
So on Windows, the good thing is that we can just host it on a network share, but on Linux, we actually had to do this in a post-auth mechanism.
So we actually had to authenticate and then upload the zip file in a post-auth way.
But on Windows, you can just do a network share and forget about all this stuff and you can just point it to your SMB and then get it to pull it from there.
But, but on, uh, on this, uh, target for this event we were looking at, um, we, we were able to get a file, um, in a known location, um, that we were able to load through this API endpoint.
And, and we, we were able to achieve SSRF out of the box quite easily, but really we wanted RCE, right?
So that's, that's what we always aim for.
Um, so what we found was, um, this isolated VM sandbox, there was actually a number of default modules that was made available to it.
Um, one of them was to load parquet files and I had never been familiar with parquet files.
And really I, I, I started digging into this more, but this is when I tapped on Riotak's shoulder.
Now I have, uh, never worked with Riotak before, but I only have some of the best things to say about him.
Um, I was very, very impressed working with him and we had a lot of fun explaining this together.
I know you've also had many experiences working with him, so you would understand.
Dude, he's something else, man.
He really is.
He's something else.
Unbelievable.
Yeah.
And neither of us had worked with parquet files or duck DB or any of these different components, but, uh, we, we were slowly getting there.
So what we found was it would load a parquet file and within the parquet file, we would be able to basically cause a SQL injection when it loads it into duck DB.
So they were using duck DB and they were loading a parquet file.
And within that process, there was a SQL injection, which we could SQL inject into duck DB.
Now duck DB is a relatively newish database technology that's being used a bit more commonly, which is really interesting because duck DB has a lot of functionalities, which I think are inherently quite insecure.
Uh, the fact like you can create files, you can, you can do all sorts of things through duck DB.
That's, you know, quite sensitive.
Now the only reason why all of this worked was because these modules were being basically inherited within the isolated VM sandbox.
So we were using, um, server side code that was already inherited in the isolated VM sandbox that could let us escape the sandbox essentially.
Ah, interesting.
So this is, this is how it worked, but we still had a few more roadblocks.
So we basically construct a zip that has parquet file that loads parquet file from the URL that then leads to the SQL injection that then leads to duck DB doing something naughty.
But what actually happened was we weren't able to get duck DB to execute that injected SQL, uh, when we loaded into duck DB.
Now that was probably because we weren't actually triggering that portion of SQL that we had injected.
So what we had to do then is we had to leverage the first SSRF we had in this chain, uh, to communicate to a different port on the server, which was responsible for managing duck DB and then trigger a refresh or load of that table inside duck DB.
Which would then lead to the far right.
Oh my gosh.
It's almost like a, it's like a delayed SQL injection there.
That's right.
We do need that second step to get that SQL injection to trigger.
Oh my gosh.
So we were able to get there, but the problem was, um, where do we write to now?
This was a, this was a modern Java application and a lot of modern Java applications.
They don't actually have JSP handlers.
They, they basically like, if you look at any modern spring Java application, they don't actually need to have the ability to put it in.
And then they have the ability to process and, and render JSP files.
So this modern Java application, we go through these several different web apps inside the Tomcat directory.
And we, we, we really struggled to find a location to, to write this, uh, JSP shell, um, which we thought was the most logical way to exploit this.
Which you got from the arbitrary, right?
On duck.
That's right.
Okay.
Yeah, that's right.
So we, at this point, we've got an arbitrary file, right?
Through many, many different stages of exploitation, but we don't know where to write the file to get the command execution.
So that's kind of where we were stuck on for a little bit.
And what we found was, um, in, in, uh, in Tomcat in web XML files, sometimes there is a, uh, specific handler, um, for exceptions.
And this was one of the only locations that we found where we could exploit this.
Um, there was this, for one of the web applications, there was a handler for 500, uh, for 500 errors, for exceptions that was pointing to a JSP file inside one of the tag library, uh, tag library folders.
So what we did was we replaced that JSP file that was a handler for 500 exceptions, and we replaced that with our shell.
And then we, um, uh, then we basically, uh, uh, exploited this by triggering a 500 error in the application that then triggered our arbitrary code from that whole process.
So at the end, uh, we had command execution, but that was, that was the chain.
Um, so I don't know if you have any questions or any, any, uh, comments on this chain.
So, so one, I, it's crazy that at the end it's like, okay, now I need to trigger a 500 error.
Like now I've got to find some unhandled exception that just screws this whole system up.
That's crazy.
Okay.
So I'm trying to, trying to follow with all of this, just, I'm going to try to recap it a little bit here and you, you, you catch me where I, I, I get it wrong.
So we find this, this, um, compiled node JS, uh, binary that is, is, you know, mapped to a specific route.
You hit that, you can hit it on authenticated.
You can upload a zip file.
That zip file will run JS code in isolated VM.
And then from there we are trying to, we need to have that, the code inside of that, um, run something that triggers the SQL injection.
So that's the part where you lost me.
Yeah.
So basically there are a lot of default functions within this SDK.
One of those functions is to load a parquet file.
And when, when it loads the parquet file from a URL, it will then load it into DuckDB.
And that's where you got the SSRF.
Okay.
So it loads the parquet file from the, and that's why.
No, that's where I got the SQL injection.
So the SSRF is separate as well.
Oh my gosh.
It's such a complex bug.
Yeah.
No, I apologize.
So basically you've, you've got a, you've, you've got a endpoint that loads a zip file that then runs inside an isolated VM.
You can achieve SSRF quite easily.
Um, but we want to escape the isolated VM to get command execution.
Right.
So the way we do that is let's just say we already have our SSRF ready on one side, ready to go.
Sure.
Now, now we load a second zip file, which does loads the parquet that loads the DuckDB SQL injection.
Then we use that first SSRF to trigger that SQL injection, uh, through a different port that then refreshes that DuckDB table.
And that lets us write anywhere on the system.
Um, and then when we want to write on the system, we've got to find a place.
And since it's a modern Java application, the only location we could find was a exception handler within the web XML and rewriting that 500.jsb, which was to handle 500 exceptions.
And then triggering a 500 exception would lead to the RC.
Okay.
So I'm going to try to recap it here.
I think, I think I got this.
So we, uh, find the, uh, the route, the unauthenticated route.
We upload to there.
Then there's some sort of SDK where you can trigger the parsing of a park parkette file.
Is that right?
Yeah.
And then that, that you get the SQL injection from there, but it's time it's delayed.
It needs to be triggered.
So use the SSRF to trigger that SQL injection that gets you arbitrary file.
Right.
And then you write into the JSV file.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It's a, it's, it's definitely one of my favorite bugs by far.
And you know, it's, it's pretty crazy.
Um, how did you do that?
Yeah.
How did you end up triggering the 500?
Uh, we, uh, basically.
Without giving too much information away on the target.
No, we, we, we caused a null pointer exception, uh, within the application to, to trigger the
500.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
And, um, it was also funny cause the application was load balanced.
So you had to hit it five or 10 times before you got the shell to show up.
Of course for, for just for the heck of it there, just add that extra variable to it.
Wow.
Dude.
That is a crazy bug and a masterpiece.
So thank you for sharing that with us, man.
Uh, no problem.
And yeah, I just want to give a shout out to riot attack as well.
Who worked on this with me.
Um, very, very enjoyable process.
And I think, uh, he'll remember this one fondly as well for the years to come.
Dude.
Typical subs.
I'm literally just sitting here still after listening to that again and just being like,
wow, what an absolute masterpiece, man.
The, the, the, the time delayed, you know, SQL injection.
What is that, man?
It's so crazy.
It's nuts, dude.
Wow.
Um, well definitely shout out to Shubs on that one.
That was, uh, amazing.
And of course, uh, Odio Tuck as well.
Great work, gentlemen.
Great work.
All right.
Next one up is, uh, is Matt Brown.
Let's go see what he's got.
So NTP is a, a bug and, and NTP issues are a bug class that, uh, some people, uh, find impactful.
Some people don't, but they're, I find them interesting, uh, because I like to go back to my roots.
Of looking at data as it goes across the wire.
So, uh, so this bug that I found, uh, was on a, uh, an IOT device that had parental controls, right?
So a parent could hand this device to their child and they could, uh, browse, you know, a, a limited set of media and they could do that in a safe way.
And the other thing parents could do, there was this feature where they could set a bedtime.
And then, and so during a certain time as a, as a parent, you know, I'm, I'm drawn to these kinds of features.
Right.
So, uh, so there was a feature in this device where you could set a bedtime where all of the media would be disabled, uh, during the bedtime.
And so anytime where an application is telling you no, because of what time it is, uh, Douglas Day has this great talk where he talks about looking for the nose in an application.
What a legendary talk, dude.
Yeah.
That talk was so good.
It's so simple and yet so profound.
And so what I guess I'm introducing here is one of the ways that an application can tell you no is by what time it is.
Mm.
Is by where is, is, is, is, is when is a, is, is a way that an application can tell, you know.
And so if that is occurring, especially in a mobile app or an IOT device, then you have to ask, where is it getting that time data from?
Right.
So, uh, NTP is the most common protocol you see to, uh, acquire, uh, time data.
And so it's one of two protocols actually in 2024 that by and large is still flying around the internet, unencrypted, unauthenticated.
Right?
Love that for us.
Yeah.
It's great.
And the other one, it's interesting.
It's actually an interesting use case.
The other one is DNS, but DNS, we just assume that it's not trusted.
And then we do things like certificate verification to, to, to get, to build trust on top of something that's not trustworthy.
Right.
And so, uh, on this device, I was able to a spoof, uh, NTP, I was able to spoof what time it is.
And to do this, I use a tool called DeLorean.
Mm.
And so, you know, aptly named, right.
Solid.
I can see where they got it.
Yeah.
If you're, if you're doing some time travel, you gotta use DeLorean.
Right.
And so, all it is, is it's just a spoof, you know, NTP server that you can intercept the NTP traffic with and provide whatever time you want.
Mm.
And so, on this, on this IoT device, we were able to, uh, bypass the bedtime for, for, for the child by, uh, by spoofing that it was like the middle of the day when the bedtime was set for nighttime.
Right.
And then you're able to bypass those, uh, those parental controls in that way.
Very cool, man.
And so, if you're not a parent, you might not think that that's like a cool threat model, but I've found similar threats in things like smart locks.
Mm.